qui dit que des choses jusqu'à quand
vous l'écoutez c'est un médecin un
médecin pour soigner un malade le malade
vient vous voir et bien pas vouloir
qu'on vous dit ressort mercedi col de
lépine merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
à
pour tenter de limiter l'impact de cette
crise économique liée aux colis de 19 un
plan de soutien à hauteur de 110
milliards d'euros a été déployée
restaurons société d'événementiel disent
indépendants vont mettre la clé sous la
porte
quelles que soient les aides qui leur
seront accordés la casse derrière si
l'économie ne repart pas si la confiance
ne repart pas elle va être terrible vous
savez aujourd'hui on perd près d'un
million d'euros par jour et on peut
considérer que non seulement avril mais
aussi le mois de mai sont désormais
certains est fermé donc c'est près de 50
millions d'euros qu'on a perdus dans ces
deux mois on résout le truc en laissant
en laissant les choses se faire et en
bloquant complètement le l'économie
française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour une heure et demie d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités et nos reporters sur le
terrain une émission essentiellement
consacrée à la crise du coroner virus en
france et dans le monde
voici les titres une bonne rentrée
scolaire plutôt qu'une rentrée en nombre
emmanuel macron a tenté de rassurer et
dissiper les inquiétudes ce matin lors
d'une visite dans une école la région
parisienne emmanuel macron qui a précisé
que des décisions pour le déconfinement
seront prises jeudi prochain l'issue
d'un conseil de défense le gouvernement
retire finalement le service controversé
d un fox coronavirus de son site
cette page qui répertoriait des liens
vers des articles de médias français
étaient censés lutter contre les pètes
news en ces temps de crise sanitaire
elle a suscité l'indignation d'une
trentaine d'associations de journalistes
le syndicat national des journalistes
avaient déposé un recours hier devant le
conseil d'état
[Musique]
le déconfinement s'accélère en europe et
encouragés par la baisse des décès liés
aux coronavirus de nombreux pays ont
allégé leurs mesures de restriction zoom
notamment aujourd'hui sur l'islande qui
rouvre ses lycées et universités avec
des règles de distanciation le royaume
uni devient le pays européen le plus
touché en terme de mortalité avec plus
de 32000 décès
[Musique]
un mot tout d'abord sur le bilan de
l'épidémie de coronavirus dans
l'hexagone qui vient de tomber on compte
25 mille cinq cent trente et un décès au
total dans notre pays
la direction générale de la santé
annonce ces dernières 24 heures une
hausse du nombre de morts 2 330 le solde
reste négatif en réanimation avec 266
malades ducobu de 19 ans - du côté de la
carte la région hôte france passant
orange en raison de la baisse de la
tension hospitalière rassurer et
convaincre le chef de l'état s'est donc
exprimé à l'issue d'une visite dans une
école de poissy dans les yvelines restée
ouverte pendant le confinement pour
accueillir des enfants de soigner en
notamment accompagné de jean-michel
blanquer le président échanger avec des
enseignants et des enfants insistant sur
l'importance des gestes barrières
il est revenu également sur le protocole
sanitaire très strict qui doit encadrer
la réouverture des écoles et qui
inquiète bon nombre de maires de
communes notamment le chef de l'état a
tenté de rassurer le monde on ne dira
jamais un enseignant pour qui les
conditions ne sont pas remplies
vous devez aller travailler physiquement
c'est pas possible et donc on est en
train de s'assurer par ce travail
formidable des directeurs et directrices
d'école que les conditions sont remplies
il y aura une autre organisation et donc
soyez rassurés là dessus c'est à dire
que les classes seront plus petites le
temps organiser différemment autour de
2,4 temps de la vie des enfants
il y aura le temps les enfants sont à
l'école comme on est là dans une classe
y aura le temps où les enfants rouges de
l'étude dirigée ce qui permet d'avoir
des classes moins nombreuses
il y aura le temps où là aussi avec les
communes et un engagement y compris
financier de l'état on va organiser une
vie qui est pédagogique mais non
scolaires c'est ce que le ministre
appelle les deux aces de ces c'est à
dire on va faire du sport du du civisme
citoyenneté de la culture
donc on va demander aux acteurs sportifs
aux acteurs aussi culturel de s'engager
avec nous à l'école dans une période où
moi je veux qu'on l'ait on les
accompagne parce que même peuvent plus
travailler et je leur demandais sur la
base du volontariat de venir nous aider
à enseigner différemment à nos enfants
et puis il y aura un tank continuera à
se faire à distance
à la maison et pour parler de cette
prise de parole surprise des manuels
macro nous sommes en direct avec jacques
myard mail mer et l'air de maisons
laffitte bonsoir jacques myard merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors vous faisiez vous partie des
maires signataires d'une tribune pour
demander de repousser la réouverture des
écoles à une date ultérieure à ce que le
président vous a rassuré ce matin
écoutez premièrement le président a
visité une section une école où
véritablement les professeurs
accueillent des enfants de soignants
nous avons tous ce genre d'expérience et
nous savons tous que lass c'est
parfaitement gérable parce que c'est un
tout petit effectif
une dizaine d'enfants et on ne peut pas
généraliser ça c'est là où il ya un
problème parce qu'on nous a montré
effectivement un président en bavardant
avec des enfances lavant les mains et
intérêts gens des enfants ça c'est
d'accord mais ça ne correspond pas à la
réalité de l'ouverture massive des
écoles et c'est là où il ya un problème
c'est qu'en réalité on voit très bien
que si on veut véritablement recevoir
tous les enfants et on nous a donné un
ordre de priorité ce sont des enfants
des soignants
ce sont les enfants de la poste ce sont
les enfants qui sont en rodage scolaire
et là on voit bien qu'on bute sur
véritablement des mesures sanitaires qui
sont extrêmement draconiennes où la
notion de groupe doit être la notion où
on a quinze enfants et il ne peut pas se
mélanger
lorsque le président vient d'exposer à
l'instant qu'on va faire entrer d'autres
personnes et cetera
il n'en demeure pas moins que cette
notion de groupe d'une quinzaine
d'enfants qui doit être là même toute la
journée
pose de multiples problèmes
d'organisation et c'est en cela que
véritablement on ne peut pas se tromper
alors qu'aqmi a pardonné mans vannes et
dans le détail on va découvrir à l'écran
peut-être ces quelques mesures et les 63
pages sur ce protocole sanitaire parmi
les plus importantes on le voit 1,4
mètre carré disponible pour chaque élève
ce que obligatoire pour les enseignants
de maternelle notamment repas pris à la
cantine 2 préférence distance d'un mètre
entre les élèves en classe ou dans les
couloirs c'est cela ce sont ces mesures
qui nous semble extrêmement
contraignantes voire impossible à mettre
en oeuvre dans certaines écoles alors qu
il est bien évident lorsque vous a
intéressé à des enfants qui ont je
dirais six sept huit ans ça va être
extrêmement complexe parce que les
enfants il ya un moment il explose
voyez ce que je veux dire et d'ailleurs
dans la visite du président de la
république nous avons vu deux enfants
qui étaient très proches les uns des
autres et qui se tapent hôtel un an sur
l'autre
donc on voit bien que cette gymnastique
ces mesures barrières elles sont
extrêmement difficile à mettre en oeuvre
à ce stade et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes un certain nombre d
attention ce n'est pas jouable
ensuite on a parlé des études dirigées
qui est ce qui va défaire parce que le
problème il est là c'est qu'un enfant
s'il rentre le matin vers 8h30 9h et qui
restent jusqu'à 19 heures parce qu'il
faut que les parents travaillent
il est évident que à ce titre les corps
enseignant ne va pas être capable
véritablement de dispenser son savoir
pendant cette longue durée et on risque
de faire appel à ce que nous appelons
les animateurs des centres de loisirs et
c'est bien évidemment une charge énorme
je dis bien énorme pour les communes
voir les parents donc on est dans une
situation où il faut ré ouvrir les
écoles je suis d'accord il faut remettre
la france au travail mais on voit très
bien aujourd'hui que l'ensemble des
mesures barrières qu'on veut nous
imposer et notamment à travers cette
notion de groupe avant les choses
quasiment la chimère tout même emmanuel
macron affirme qu'il n'y aura pas de
contrainte ni pour les mères qui refuse
d'ouvrir ni pour les enseignants qui ne
souhaitent pas reprend 10 précise plutôt
une bonne rentrée qu'une rentrée en
nombre ça laisse tout de même une marge
de manoeuvre non oui bien évidemment
mais vous allez avoir la pression des
parents épuisés pour l'instant sont sur
la base du volontariat il ne souhaite
pas tous les trois leurs enfants aller
où vous avez aussi un autre
est ce que les professeurs vont pouvoir
accepter ses conditions
or c'est là où il ya un problème car
nous vous savez qu'il ya un système dual
bien sûr les mairies mettent à
disposition d'un certain nombre de
moyens matériels mais il y a le corps
professoral qui a son mot à dire
donc l'adéquation des deux n'est pas
toujours évidente
donc je crois que effectivement il va
falloir un peu plus de temps c'est
évident il faut y aller progressivement
là je suis d'accord mais il ne faut pas
se leurrer on n'a pas trouvé encore la
pierre philosophale pour résoudre tout
ça alors jacques myard y avait un autre
point qui chagrinait les mères c'est
celui de la responsabilité en bref si un
enfant tombe malade il peut peut-être
poursuivre le maire de sa commune en
tout cas c'est la craindre la cnil qui
flotte sur ce point emmanuel macron dit
on ne voit pas donner le sentiment qu'il
y aurait une amnistie pour les élus je
pense qu'il nous faut préciser la loi
bien cadrer les choses je ne veux pas
que les maires soient menacés ou
inquiété au delà de leurs propres
responsabilités s'avoue satisfait cette
réponse un petit peu diffusé que ça ne
dépend ni du président de la république
ni l'éducation nationale mais in fine et
du juge
et c'est là où effectivement il ya pas
mal d'interrogations
ce qui est clair c'est que le maire il
fait le maximum
il a pas véritablement une obligation de
résultat une obligation de moyens tout
mettre en oeuvre et éviter effectivement
la faute intentionnelle
s'il se rend compte que véritablement
c'est impossible
s'il se rend compte qu'il est en train
de mettre des enfants en danger
là ils doivent absolument arrêter le
système et ne pas poursuivre je suis pas
trop je dirais inquiet à ce titre mais
il est vrai qu'on peut avoir de
multiples ensuite procédure parce que
vous le savez très bien que cela dépend
de chacun de faire un procès et vous
trouverez toujours des hommes de loi
pour dire on va y aller on ne sait
jamais on peut gagner mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que la responsabilité
des élus est totale j'ai dit un jour que
nous étions tous du gibier de mise en
examen
et bien c'est possible mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que nous sommes aussi
des gens responsables et nous sommes
capables de faire face la réalité c'est
que de toute façon nous sommes obligés
de vivre
nous sommes obligés de ré ouvrir des
écoles mais qu'on nous donne un peu de
temps qu'on nous donne aussi des normes
qui soit plus acceptable et qu'on nous
laisse travailler
ça prendra du temps se soit pas faite
demain matin merci beaucoup jacques
myard d'avoir été en direct sur rt
france alors comment les professeurs ont
ils réagi à cette visite et aux propos
d' emmanuel macron pour nicolas glières
professeur de français à paris
administrateur du mouvement les stylos
rouges l'attitude de l'est du chef de
l'état est tout simplement irresponsable
il est dit qu'il fallait éviter le
brassage l'école c'est le lieu du
brassage des millions d'enfants vont se
retrouver de nouveau en contact des
millions les élèves de france des
millions donc ils vont se retrouver en
contact pouvoir se refiler tous les
virus qui vont passer puisque étant
confiné il n'était pas en contact donc
là les virus pour circuler pas seulement
de covin d'ailleurs donc tout le monde
va tomber malade ça va être super les
adultes aussi au passage et puis tout le
monde va se refiler ça dans tous les
sens le cosy de aussi ce brassage non
voulues lorsque les gens se déplacent à
plus de 100 km et leurs alliés ont fait
au sein des villes d'où au sein de leurs
écoles qui vont être de vrais
laboratoire de deux virus quoi
concrètement nous moi ce que je retiens
aussi c'est qu'on va être des cobayes
concrètement on va voir comment ça se
passe alors on remet les profs dans les
écoles on remet les personnels on
regarde ce que ça donne sur les enfants
les parents auraient pu on avisera après
mais c'est complètement irresponsable et
la réaction présent de la classe
politique elle aussi très prolixe en
voici quelques-unes l'opération de
communication dernière macron dans une
école à poissy aura au moins prouvé une
chose rouvrir les écoles dès le 11 mai
est une décision irresponsable reportant
la réouverture des écoles en septembre
pour garantir une rentrée en toute
sûreté
je crois que macro est définitivement
hors sol de la réalité il n'a aucune
idée de l'angoissé des parents et des
enseignants
il ne comprend pas pourquoi ce 11 mai
ressemble à une roulette russe emmanuel
macron surjoue l'optimisme mais reste
sourd à l' angoisse de millions de
familles enseignants personnel une
rentrée dans ces conditions le 11 mai
est impossible ce n'est pas le moment
d'être bravache monsieur le président
écouter les français
reporter la rentrée et on l'aura compris
malgré les mots rassurants du chef de
l'état à quelques jours donc de ce
retour à l'école progressive des enfants
l'inquiétude monte chez les enseignants
et certains parents alors le protocole
sanitaire est il suffisant les parents
doivent-ils avoir peur c'est l'objet de
notre face à face et pour en parler nous
sommes avec un benjamin amar enseignants
porte parole cgt du val de marne à ses
côtés ou face à face comme on préfère
nicolas bay ce conseiller municipal de
wingles ex député ps du pas de calais
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors pas
de contrainte on nous dit emmanuel
macron demeetra aucun professeur en
danger benjamin amar est ce que vous
êtes enfin un enseignant rassuré ce soir
en aucun cas on obtient kg j'ai regardé
la petite mise en scène de l'après midi
bon je peux vous dire que moi je suis en
contact avec bon nombre d'enseignants du
fait de mes responsabilités syndicales
est d'abord avec ceux qui sont mes
collègues au lycée gutenberg de créteil
et honnêtement le le l'état d'esprit et
moi d'aider des collègues que j'ai c'est
maintenant c'est plus l'inquiétude et la
colère c'est la colère devant à la fois
tant d'amateurisme et en d'entêtement
je rappelle voilà factuellement les
autres foyers de kloster comparable à la
france ce que ça sert à rien de nous
comparer avec la norvège où il ya eu
vingt fois moins de cas mais par exemple
l'espagne l'italie l'état de new york
est bien là la rentrée elle est reportée
sine die et elle est reportée en
septembre
je rappelle qu'il est à 60% des français
qui sont opposés effectivement à cette
rentrée le 11 mai à 59% des français qui
effectivement disent clairement qu'ils
ne remettront pas leurs enfants à
l'école donc on assiste à une véritable
mascarade un entêtement finalement
emmanuel macron que ce soit à l'opinion
des français sur la réforme des
retraites où l'opinion des français sur
la santé publique pendant le coc vide et
ben i excusez-moi l'expression mais ils
s'en tamponnent allègre ment et et il va
le payer politiquement ce qui est clair
et net c'est que nous à la cgt on est en
train d'organiser à la cgt educ'action
syndicats la campagne du droit de
retrait parce que la santé des salariés
la santé des enseignants la santé des
élèves
eh bien il n'y a pas de choses plus
importantes que ça et les aléas macro ni
gist finalement maintenant nous
indiffère nicolas bailly est votre
réaction
d'abord on j'apprécie la mesure des
propos de monsieur amar comme d'habitude
la cgt qui est le syndicat le plus
politique de france qui n'est d'ailleurs
pas un syndicat qui déforme ni les
français ni les travailleurs mais qui
défend une ligne politique
révolutionnaire qu'on connaît bien
moi ma réaction c'est que un moment le
pays devra de toute manière repartir et
je ne vois pas ce qu'ils nient chance
hier ce qui sera différent d'un pays en
septembre par rapport à aujourd'hui déjà
monsieur amar c'est une fête nous seuls
l'italie a décidé de reporter sa entre
en septembre l'état de new york et
l'espagne n'ont pas encore tranché sur
la date de reprise donc vérifier vos
notes
le l'allemagne reprend l'école lieu 4
mais l'allemagne est à un cluster à peu
près similaire similaire à la france la
chine réouvre de ses écoles dans la
province de one qui est le endroit
d'origine le d'épidémie moi ce que
j'attendrais de la part de la cgt c'est
aussi des propositions parce que ce que
vous propose aujourd'hui c'était juste
de reporter la rentrée en septembre
sans expliquer comment vous vous
envisagerez de faire cette rentrée et
comment vous protégerez au mieux les
enseignants et les enfants
les mesures qui sont prises aujourd'hui
sont les mesures qui sont quand même
issu de concertation sur des mesures
progressives
à un moment le pays ne peut pas rester à
l'arrêt jusqu'en septembre quand ses
voisins européens relance notamment
leurs économies et leurs écoles
c'est à la fois dangereux pour la
stabilité du pays mais c'est aussi
dangereux pour le décrochage scolaire
de beaucoup d'enfants qui aujourd'hui je
parle avec beaucoup d'enseignants qui
aujourd'hui sont complètement au
décrochage et n'ont plus aucun lien avec
l'école
benjamin marche si vous le voulez bien
on va justement regarder en cette
infographie qu'on a déjà découvertes
tout à l'heure ce protocole sanitaire 63
pages on les a évidemment pas tout
résumer ici quatre mètres carrés pour
les enfants mais ce qu bigard thouars
pour les enseignants distance d'un mètre
ça ne vous rassure pas vous trouvez ça
court ou tout simplement non applicable
à benjamin a marre
non mais alors bon d'abord effectivement
la question qui se pose c'est la
question des moyens c'est-à-dire l'accès
aux masques gratuits ainsi possible
merci bien
parce que s'il s'agit là en l'occurrence
de personnels qui vont travailler le
l'accès aux tests sérologiques voilà
tout simplement
mais je voudrais réagir aux propos de
monsieur j'adore d'abord recevoir des
conseils de défense des travailleurs de
la part d'un socialiste renégats ça me
plaît énormément
ensuite je suis désolé mais les
déclarations du gouvernement espagnol
sont créés vont clairement dans le sens
d'un report de la rentrée et il en va de
même dans l'état de new york qui on se
donne rendez-vous lorsque les décisions
tomberont ensuite
excusez moi mais le laquelle la cgt est
là monsieur visiblement stevo qui
devrait aller regarder vos notes
la cgt elle est force de proposition
elle assortit énormément de documents
d'ailleurs philippe martinez est en lien
permanent avec le gouvernement et le
gouvernement connaît très bien nos
conditions bien évidemment qu'il faut
reprendre le boulot
bien évidemment que la reprise de
l'activité économique est crucial mais
ya quelque chose là dessus c'est la
santé des gens on n'envoie pas les gens
au casse-pipe voyez vous donc et c'est
marre je me permets de vous arrêter
parce que emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
dis clairement ne mettra aucun
professeur en danger les enseignants
souhaitent sous s'ils le souhaitent
peuvent ne pas reprendre le travail y
compris pour les mères qui voit là ne
souhaite pas organiser
donc quand même il ya une marge de
manoeuvre assez grande proposé par le
chef de l'état aujourd'hui attendu non
non entre eux et ne tenait pas la
confusion la chance et ça je le fait
qu'elles viennent et nous les mettrons
vous n'êtes pas obligés de partir
mais c'est moi vous n'avez pas
interrompu monsieur vous n'avez pas
interdit pour monsieur laissez-moi
terminé en anglais et leur donnera la
parole effectivement nicolas bailly qui
vous répondra voilà merci bien les
sédunois répondent de manière oui merci
en l'occurrence but je vais vous
répondre madame en l'occurrence en
reprenant tel quel cet argument là c'est
très étonnant
dc emmanuel macron veut clarifier les
choses mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne
reporte pas la rentrée tout bonnement en
l'occurrence vous savez quoi
le nombre de journées qui vont
effectivement être effective pour les
élèves va être ridicule
1 on le sait très bien la rentrée
scolaire
l'année scolaire elle est foutue elle et
sa beauté savait dès le son de mon
interlocuteur sur le décrochage scolaire
la bonne blague
moi comme mes collègues on est rentré
dans l'éducation nationale pour lutter
contre les inégalités scolaires
ça va pas se jouer au mois de juin vous
voyez vous ça y est c'est clair l'année
elle est complètement particulière
la situation est totalement particulière
tout comme l'activité économique on est
dans une situation exceptionnelle
il ya encore énormément d'incertitudes
donc voilà la rentrée scolaire on règle
le dont rêve le sujet l'opinion elle est
ultra majoritairement effectivement pour
le report en septembre et en septembre
on reprendra une activité scolaire
normal qu est ce que c est et puis
qu'est ce que c'est que toute cette
discussion sur l'insécurité juridique
qu'est ce que c'est que cette injection
d'un effet pardonnez-moi nicolas bailly
ce vous répondrai après on passera
attention à votre échelle qui ne
contente pas dessus benjamin a marre ça
serait dommage à côté de vous voilà
nicolas balises peut-être que vous
pourriez répondre effectivement bon la
langue d'ailleurs argumentation de
benjamin elma j'apprécie les talons de
monsieur visionnaire de monsieur amar
qui nous dit qu'ils en septembre la
rentrée se passera rien la semence là le
coc vider le kobe 19 sera encore en
septembre et on fait quoi en septembre
aujourd'hui toutes les mesures qui ont
été prises par leur commune par le
gouvernement sur des recommandations de
scientifiques permettent justement
d'appréhender au mieux cette rentrée de
manière très progressive très concertée
et monsieur amar sachez que les
enseignants par exemple qui ont des
problèmes de santé qui sont des
personnes à risque ont déjà été
contactés pour pour ne pas retourner à
l'école et il ya la base du volontariat
qui a été rappelé par le prise en mains
publiques aujourd'hui base du
volontariat à la fois pour les
enseignants et pour les collectivités
parce qu'il faut rappeler ce qu'est la
trappe t1 mes anciens collègues juste
avant dans l'émission
que le problème est dû à un psy vous
invite d'un côté d'éducation nationale
qui gère les corps enseignant et vous
avez des collectivités locales qui
gèrent les locaux dans lesquels ont lieu
les cours les recommandations du
gouvernement de 4 mètres carrés pas
élèves peuvent être appliqués dans les
écoles comme ma ville à lens et ne
peuvent pas être impliqué dans certaines
écoles qui sont d'un modèle plus ancien
ou qui n'ont pas la même place donc ça
sera de toute manière au cas par cas
dans la dentelle
que ça soit en mai ou en septembre comme
dix neuf stades en septembre et les
tests sérologiques me chammas
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que les
tests sérologiques n'ont aucune valeur
parce que moi qui ai eu copie de 19 et
comme vous et je suis content que vous
en soyez sortie pour rochus en débat de
ce soir on a eu que 10 19 on peut pas
nous dire aujourd'hui si on ne peut pas
leur ai attrapé ou non et on les tests
sérologiques aujourd'hui son sont
inopérantes tandis qu'au test pour
savoir si les gens sont malades ou pas
ils n'ont la valeur comment monde le
test est réalisé
un quart d'heure après vous rencontrez
des gens dans la rue le test n'a déjà
plus de valeur ces tests ces tests pour
tester les les personnes ne sont
intéressants que quand vous tester des
mâles que vous pouvez après isolé mais
tu espères des personnes négatif vous
serez incapable de tester 67 millions de
français tous les jours
l'allemagne avait commencé des campagnes
massives de test et aujourd'hui elle
revient en arrière sur cette stratégie
de campagne massive parce qu'elle se
rend compte que c'est inutile c'est
inefficients là ce que les cinq
campagnes de tests efficience et de
tester les personnes qui présentent des
premiers symptômes du comique pour les
isoler et à la fois isolé leurs proches
et benjamin marc la réponse non mais
attends mais c'est formidable c'est à
dire que dans la macro nyon nous a
expliqué il ya trois mois que les masses
ça ne servait à rien sous toutes les
coutures pour finalement nous dire bah
finalement si les mains c'est vachement
important on a vite on avait bien
compris à l'époque que l'argumentaire
sur les masques il était conditionnée
par la disponibilité en masse et donc
maintenant ce sont les tests qui ne
servent à rien je rappelle que si
l'allemagne a géré par justin sont des
cons qui attendait monsieur je ne vous
ai pas couper la parole d'accor donc je
vous ai laissé ressortir votre litanie
c'est bon vous paraît donc en
l'occurrence maintenance et les tests
qui ne servent à rien c'est tout à fait
nouveau
mais vous savez monsieur on devrait vous
invitez je pense dans les séminaires
scientifiques ou au conseil scientifique
parce que
vous savez vous avez plein de certitudes
moi je vais vous dire effectivement que
j'ai attrapé le coc vite comme vous et
lorsque j'ai discuté y compris avec les
médecins qui m'ont soigné
j'ai bien compris et c'est toujours le
cas quand on regarde aujourd'hui les
informations et qu'on écoute
effectivement les spécialistes qu'il ya
bien plus d'incertitudes que de
certitudes
donc là vous êtes très incertain hâtif
vous êtes très péremptoire sur la
question des tests et c'est très
étonnant
et je vais vous dire la seule vérité
effectivement qu'on peut dire aux
français aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya
plein d'éléments qu'on ne connaît pas
s'ils pouvaient entre qui pouvait
évoquer la maladie de kawasaki ya encore
quinze jours
donc effectivement vous avez dit mais en
septembre le virus il sera là oui mais
on se laisse en l'occurrence un petit
peu de temps pour justement ce enfin
proposer des critères de santé publique
aux français qui tiennent la route sur
les masques parce que sur les masques là
aussi c'est la complète incertitude on
nous disait il ya pas masquer la grande
distribution nous explique qu'elle a des
stocks monstrueux alors que c'était la
pénurie encore il ya quinze jours donc
les français n'y comprennent rien et
encore une fois sur la question des
transports sur la question de l'école
sur la question de la sécurité dans
l'entreprise
on a des tas de choses à mettre en place
et il faut du temps l'école le lui la
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire je
le dis et je le répète c'est la raison
une des raisons qui m'ont poussé à
devenir enseignant bon sang de bonsoir
c'est pas sur le mois de mai et sur le
mois de juin
tendant à l'est un mois et demi de cours
que ça va se jouer en management marc
jordan et moi on va le sait aussi récent
nicolas bismes épingle le président
brouille deux mois sans école vous êtes
enseignant vous le savez deux mois sans
école ça peut être aussi traumatisant
pour certains enfants pour qui fait
compliqué de faire des devoirs toute la
journée
voilà qui est parent c'est ça c'est
qu'est ce que vous répondez pardon mais
je réponds une chose très simple madame
encore une fois je répète je lis
excusez-moi j'ai été à l'hôpital
j'ai été en service de réanimation
madame je sais ce que c'est ta forme
grave du code vide c'est une peste
d'accord alors moi je dis ah ça c'est
quoi
oui c'est vrai deux mois sans école
c'est problématique halléguen service de
réanimation pour ce pour cette paix est
là c'est bien plus grave
donc encore une fois la santé publique
c'est ce qui compte le plus est ce que
vous ne dites pas quand même et je suis
très étonné
le mot de la fin nicolas bailly si
effectivement derrière il n'y avait pas
un lien entre les pressions patronales
pour la reprise de l'activité économique
et cette obsession sur l'école ça c'est
très étonnant mais personne n'est dupe
alors les patrons enfin l'économie des
français en général est peut-être voilà
que tout le monde devra payer un moment
donné nicolas bailly selon le mot de la
fin la réponse à benjamin hammam
monsieur mois pour être issu d'une
famille d'enseignants pour avoir
enseigné aussi moi même pendant quelques
années et pour avoir encore beaucoup
dansé dans la fa lui j'ai beaucoup de
gens de ma famille qui enseigne
aujourd'hui à des enfants de personnels
hospitaliers à des enfants qui ne
peuvent pas faire autrement qu'elle est
calé à l'école des écoles tourner dans
notre pays il faut qu'on trouve des
solutions ensemble
moi je suis partisan de l'unité
nationale face à cette maladie qui est
je le sais une maladie horrible terrible
qui malheureusement ne sera pas de
circuler dans les deux années qui
viennent et qu'il faudra apprendre à
vivre avec prendre des mesures avec
canto pas quant au patron et la pression
patronale de toute manière l'économie
reprendra que les écoles on ne
reprennent pas aidé incombera
malheureusement en france et de gérer
leurs enfants chez eux
le chômage partiel sont pas de travail
les bacilles démonter monsieur la
sécurité oui ben la sécurité au travail
des entreprises dans ma circonscription
qui nous rendait n'y a aucun problème
qui tourne à 100 % de leurs salariés
mais pour que cela passe pas partout
merci benjamin hammam merci également à
nicolas bailly est d'avoir joué le jeu
de ce débat merci d'avoir été en direct
avec vous sur rt france rester avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parleront
toujours 2
cette crise du cornât virus avec cette
désinforme coronavirus rubrique sur le
site internet du gouvernement qui
faisait débat et qui a été retiré de son
site puis nous irons au royaume-uni pays
le plus touché d'europe actuellement par
locaux vides 19 ans prendra ensuite la
direction de l'islande où les lycées et
universités ont rouvert leurs portes
avec des règles de distanciation
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash vous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre en direct du rt
france 20h30 heure française deuxième
partie d'émission largement consacrée à
la crise du coronavirus dans le monde et
en europe le gouvernement retire donc
finalement le service controversé d un
fox coronavirus sur son site une page
qui répertoriait des liens vers des
articles de certains médias français
luttant contre les fêtes news concernant
le kobe 19
le syndicat national des journalistes
avaient saisi hier le conseil d'état
dénonçant une ingérence des autorités
publiques dans la liberté de la presse
un report qui semble-t-il poussé le
gouvernement à retirer sa rubrique
écoutez à ce sujet franck fr le ministre
de la culture
je peux comprendre les inquiétudes qui
ont été suscitées par ce service dans
les rédactions
parce qu'il ne s'agit absolument pas
pour l'état de labelliser les médias ou
d'orienter le choix des français vers
tel ou tel média en tant que ministre de
la culture garant de la liberté de la
presse
garant de son indépendance et du
pluralisme de la presse je souhaite donc
vous annoncer que le gouvernement a pris
la décision de retirer cette page du
site du gouvernement
j'en profite enfin pour saluer le
travail remarquable des journalistes
pendant la crise qui ont contribué
malgré les difficultés à informer nos
compatriotes et à lutter efficacement
contre les des informations
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
didier maïsto président de sud radio
bonsoir didier maïsto le gouvernement
qui finalement recul 1 et retire cette
page de son site une bonne nouvelle que
qu'est ce que vous y voyez comme finir
bonsoir oui c'est une bonne nouvelle en
tout cas c'est une vraie nouvelle ce
n'est pas une fête news comment comme on
dit et en fait ce gouvernement mais
c'est pas nouveau a semble t'il un
problème avec les médias avec
l'indépendance des médias il n'a que ces
mots à la bouche indépendance des médias
garant de l'indépendance des médias
mais je crois que le les médias eux
n'ont pas besoin du gouvernement pour
être indépendant et n'ont pas besoin
d'être garanti mais cette histoire n'est
pas n'est pas nouvelle nous l'avons vu à
l'occasion des mouvements sociaux à
l'occasion des gilet jaune est dans la
tête d'emmanuel bacon a refleuri une
vieille idée vieille lune qui a été pour
partie défendu par eux par la classe
politique sur la création vous en
souvenez j'étais venu sur votre antenne
pour dire c'était une très mauvaise idée
de ce fameux conseil de déontologie
journalistique et de médiation il s'agit
de labelliser finalement les médias qui
des endroits l'imprimatur de l'exécutif
et des médias qui sont censés aux pages
et des fausses levé alors les commandes
signé mais cette nouvelle section a
présenté un parce qu'elle a été retirée
des liens vers des articles de médias
ces médias donc et alors il ya ceux
effectivement qui luttent dans le cadre
de la crise sanitaire france info
libération 20 minutes
il ya donc selon le gouvernement les
bons
et mauvais élèves ça vous c'est pas à
vous que je vais la prendre à alerter
france à vous avez été souvent accusés
d'être des propagateurs de fausses
nouvelles à la solde du gouvernement
russe
alors que beaucoup de chaînes sont
financés à la fois par les français ou
par d'autres états souverains aller ça
n'a jamais posé le moindre problème on
voit bien plat contre tout à fait dans
la politique politicienne
cette liberté des français des citoyens
à elle s'est exprimée très fortement via
les réseaux sociaux
et puis il ya un certain nombre de
chaînes de stations de radio de
journalistes indépendants de gens s'ils
sont allés chimie mais les événements
dans la rue qui ont montré une
différente de différentes choses de
l'intérieur
et malheureusement il semblerait que cet
exécutif en beaucoup les médias qui vont
dans son sens et n'aime pas beaucoup
l'esprit critique donc c'est très bien
que ce cette page a été retirée
d'ailleurs je l'avais dit à cette
matière j'ai du mal à tuer recettes 10
ans du conseil de dire anthologie
puisque je les croise et juste avant le
confinement à côté de la radio et elle
m'avait proposé de faire partie de
discuter pour intégrer ce conseil il
n'en est pas question
parce que vous rendez pas compte en
réalité que vous êtes sous la coupe de
deux de l'exécutif et les médias ne
peuvent pas obéir
quel que soit le gouvernement dans un
régime démocratique
dans un régime républicain aux
injonctions des uns et des autres et
sais pas je regrette à des
fonctionnaires du service d'information
du premier ministre de décider s'ils
doivent labellisé d'une page non pas
pour cela nous avons des du public
nous prenons nos risques nous vérifions
nos informations et nouveau son oeuvre
de pluralisme de dollars
là tout le monde nous en attaque un
exemple je pense que sud radio aussi
donc nous n'avons pas besoin des savoirs
le doigt sur la couture du pantalon
c'est ce que nous faisons doit voir
l'imprimatur du gouvernement de bénéfice
du doute quand même il s'agissait d'une
crise il s'agit d'une crise sanitaire
grave
n'est-il pas important effectivement de
deux livré dans ce domaine précisément
des informations fiables et justes et et
vous le pensez peut-être un peu le but
du gouvernement quand même l'objectif
premier
j'y crois pas du tout pour être honnête
imaginez aujourd'hui je vous renvoie des
questions si un l'occasion de toutes les
faits qui news propagée par l'exécutif
je vous rappel d'histoire des masques et
libération alors que nous vous l'avions
fait dès le début libération fait une
enquête la semaine dernière et a crié au
mensonge d'état puisque le directeur
général de la santé jérôme salomon avait
dit que la stratégie de l'état avait
évolué à échanger et c'est pas du tout
du tout la stratégie n'a pas changé
songez que de 2012 a aujourd'hui on
devait comme commander 100 millions de
masques par an une seule commande a été
honoré il en est de même pour les tests
il en est de même pour tous les débats
autour de 2 litres auxi chloroquine et
imaginez si les médias s'étaient tues et
avait laissé comme ça la propagande de
l'exécutif se dérouler on serait déjà un
peu dans une forme de régime
autocratique ou dictatorial il est
heureux que les médias puissent
critiquer en toute indépendance et la
critique peut être aussi positive mais
que les débats s'organisent dans une
démocratie c'est comme ça que ça va
fonctionner rappelez-vous aussi de 2 6
bat aniane par parole du gouvernement
qui nous expliquait que les masques ne
servait à rien aujourd'hui
lohan s est là
démis de médecine et tous les gens un
petit peu sérieux dans la mesure où le
corona virus se propage par les
postillons comprendre et d suggère et
conseille fortement et une loi rendant
obligatoire le port de masque en réalité
tout ça et nous avait expliqué aussi que
nous étions tout à fait incapable de
mettre correctement à masquer alors que
cet après-midi même en fin de matinée le
président de la république s'est rendu
dans une école à enlever son masque il a
touché la réajuster un certain nombre de
fois
alors qu'on ne doit évidemment pas
touché son masque à lens il s'agit
d'avoir des béni-oui-oui et des médias
là d'autres ce sera 100 sud radio et il
est heureux seul les idiots ne changent
pas d'avis que cette page internet
délétère était retirée merci beaucoup
didier maïsto d'avoir été en direct les
au royaume uni lui est devenue le
deuxième pays au monde le plus touché
par le coronavirus derrière les etats
unis le bilan est de 32 1313 mans liés
au virus
retour sur la stratégie de gestion de
crise du gouvernement sur les
perspectives et sur les perspectives du
déconfinement avec antoine auger le cap
fatidique des 30 mille victimes a été
franchie outre manche
boris johnson avait dans un premier
temps soutenu la stratégie de l'immunité
collective à savoir laisser le virus se
propage et pour qu'une majorité soit
contaminée et développent des anticorps
coronavirus peu de temps avant d'être
lui même contrôlé positif au courant
d'un virus boris johnson a finalement
décidé le 23 mars dernier n'imposait un
confinement au royaume uni après un peu
plus d'un mois et alors que se dessine
une baisse lente mais continue des
victimes du colis 19
les autorités britanniques envisagent à
présent à déconfinement progressif afin
d'éviter une nouvelle vague de
contamination londres compte s'appuyer
sur une application de traçage ayant
recours aux données bluetooth des
smartphones pour analyser la
distanciation entre individus et mieux
détecter la propagation du virus
l'objectif de tests choix qu un stress
et de traquer et d'isoler le virus afin
qu'ils sont incapables de se reproduire
je surtout l'application nous permet
d'adopter une approche plus ciblée du
confinement tout en contenant en toute
sécurité la maladie la création de ce
système est une vaste entreprise
nationale d'une ampleur et d'une
complexité sans précédent l'application
va être testé sur la plus grande île
d'angleterre celle de wight au sud du
pays pour être généralisé à partir de
juin
si le royaume uni a vraisemblablement
passé le pic de l'épidémie
la sortie du confinement soulève de
nombreuses questions notamment sur le
retour à la vie active de milliers de
britanniques ragoubi cette gnac et
compréhensive knicks oui je présenterai
un plan complet la semaine prochaine
pour expliquer premièrement comment nous
pouvons faire bouger notre économie
deuxièmement comment nous pouvons
envoyer nos enfants à l'école ou dans
les crèches
et troisièmement comment nous pouvons
nous rendre au travail et comment nous
pouvons rendre la vie au travail plus
sur sypher depuis le début du
confinement 20% des actifs soit 6
millions de personnes sont au chômage
partiel et ont recours aux aides de
l'état
si ce rythme est jugé insoutenable par
le ministre britannique des finances
les indemnisations d'urgence du
gouvernement ne sont pas appelées à
cesser et ce en dépit de l'effondrement
économique auxquels le pays fait face
après avoir misé sur l'immunité
collective puis fait machine arrière le
royaume uni se trouve donc dans une
situation délicate face à ce qu on a un
virus avec plus de 32000 mort on l'a dit
il devient le pays européen le plus
touché par la pandémie c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
nous sommes avec bharat pangkhan ya
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous baratte
pangkhan ya j'espère que vous vous
entendez bien un bilan donc qui pourrait
en plus être sous-estimée car en compte
1 je le rappelle depuis peu les décès
dans les maisons de retraite comment
vous expliquer ce chiffre s il était
prévisible selon vous il faut que je
n'ai malheureusement beaucoup de
personnes sont morts c'est très triste
et je pense que d'ici la fin de la
journée et nous dépasserons l'italie
s'est beaucoup de personnes nous
comptons le mort à l'hôpital et les
morts en maison de retraite
effectivement les bretons est très élevé
comment vous expliquez ce très mauvais
bilan est ce que vous lui attribuez vous
à la politique du gouvernement
effectivement johnson qui misaient au
départ sur l'immunité collective on en
avait beaucoup parlé
je ne sais pas mais je pense que la
réponse est multiple un des aspects de
cette réponse est que le confinement a
été hélas il à la mise en place du
traçage a été lente et également la mise
en place de tests
de plus nous aurions immédiatement du et
des les maisons de retraite afin de
protéger les personnes qui s'y rendent
pour s'assurer que les personnes ne sont
pas infectés car si elles sont
contaminés alors elles sont très
vulnérables et beaucoup d'entre elles
mourront
effectivement vous parlez des maisons de
retraite ça a été une véritable
catastrophe sanitaire dans le pays c'est
ce qui explique ce lourd bilan au
royaume-uni précisément ce n est qu en
plus je le pense nous avons observées
dans tout le pays
une augmentation des décès dans les
maisons de retraite dans la communauté
de personnes âgées qui sont extrêmement
fragiles et vulnérables
donc malheureusement lorsqu une
affection est introduite dans une de ces
communautés alors les personnes sont
rapidement comme une eau contaminée et
beaucoup d'entre elles meurent alors
mauvaise gestion effectivement peut-être
des autorités également peut-être tout
un système de santé à revoir selon vous
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
maladies infectieuses
et puis ce n'est pas une mauvaise
gestion mais il faut être conscient que
ce problème l'année et il aurait fallu
agir en conséquence
nous avons malheureusement été très
lents dans nos actions de prévention
nous aurions dû repérer bien plutôt les
signaux d'alarmé et mettre en place des
plans d'actions immédiatement même si ce
sont des maisons de retraite privées
elles sont besoin de soutien et
d'intervention gouvernementale face à
une pandémie
comment vous expliquer justement cette
lenteur c'était un parti pris au des
autorités ou tout simplement une
sous-estimation de la gravité de cette
crise je pense effectivement qu'il ont
sous-estimé il pensait sans doute que la
contamination et la dangerosité de la
maladie serait plus parce qu'elle me
l'étais ils le seront à terme mais je
pense effectivement qu'il s'agissait
d'une sous-estimation du scénario le
pire est malheureusement le coronavirus
s'est montré extrêmement infectieux et à
contaminer beaucoup de personnes selon
vous les mesures de confinement est ce
qu'elles ont été décidées à temps où
elle aurait dû l'être plutôt sans aucun
doute nous aurions dû agir plus tôt
cela fait longtemps que nous le disent
on est
et je souhaite être honnête sur ce point
nous pensons qu'un confinement plus
rapide aurait aidé il y avait aussi le
problème tout comme en france d'ailleurs
de la pénurie de masques de test est ce
que sur ce point le gouvernement est en
train de combler son retard
nous avons mis en place un confinement
qui nous a donné le temps nécessaire
pour nous réorganiser nous avons
construit des réserves de test et de
matériel de protection
donc nous testons mais je ne pense pas
que ce sont les systèmes de traçage qui
sont suffisants donc il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à accomplir afin que
les tests et le traçage soient
opérationnels en même temps car les deux
sont nécessaires
ma dernière question c'est peut-être
plus aux citoyens que je m'adresse call
expert des maladies infectieuses quel
est l'état d'esprit les des britanniques
avec ce bilan effectivement qui est très
lourd à ce qu'ils sont inquiets ce qu'au
contraire ils revendiquent peut-être
plus de liberté comme on peut le voir
dans certains pays anglo saxons
notamment aux états unis
c'est une question très difficile car
les personnes qui ont perdu des proches
sont en deuil ne s'exprime pas sont
bouleversés et d'autre part il ya des
personnes qui n'ont pas du tout été
touchés
et ces personnes ne se rendent pas
compte du danger
donc il y a les deux aspects il ya des
personnes très touchée très triste et
d'autres personnes qui veulent que
l'économie reparte c'est un numéro
d'équilibriste difficile mais il faut
être très clair sur ce point il faut
sauver des vies cela devrait être la
priorité
merci bad company has rappelle que vous
êtes expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter au royaume uni en
russie à présent plus de 10000 à nouveau
cas en 24 heures ces derniers jours la
pandémie de kobe de 19 a connu une
progression bien plus rapide dans le
pays que dans le reste de l'europe
aujourd'hui
un haut responsable du secteur spatial
evgeniya milk in est décédé du coc vide
à l'âge de 64 ans pour autant la russie
affiche un des taux de mortalité le plus
faible d'europe avec 155 milles 370 cas
et 1451 décès seulement les autorités
russes affirment que cela est dû à la
fermeture rapide des frontières ou grand
nombre de tests effectués au suivi de
l'infection chez les personnes
contaminées et avec 1799 cas confirmés
et 10 décès liés aux combats de 19 sur
364 1000 habitants
l'islande compte à ce jour l'un des
bilans les plus faibles d'europe
les lycées professionnels et universités
ont ouvert leurs portes hier alexis
combat en europe l'islande ferait
presque figure d'exception
depuis ce lundi une partie des étudiants
de lille a repris le chemin des courts
après sept semaines passées à la maison
si certains établissements ont préféré
ne pas rouvrir pour s'éviter le casse
tête d'une réorganisation des classes
lycée professionnel et universitaire
prennent leurs programmes en douceur les
élèves semblent ravis c'est bon de
pouvoir retrouver mes amis et d'être
avec eux à nouveau
ça commençait à devenir un peu long à
mettre seul chez moi
c'est vraiment bien d'être enfant de
retour
c'est tellement difficile d'être à la
maison où l'on peut facilement
procrastiner c'est mieux d'aller à
l'école tous les jours et de retrouver
une certaine routine dans ce lycée
professionnel de la capitale du pays
règlent à vic
tout est fait pour préserver la sécurité
et la santé des élèves
ces derniers sont répartis dans
différentes zones afin de limiter les
contacts pour maintenir une distance
raisonnable entre ses élèves du
département couture plusieurs tables ont
été condamnés tous les élèves du lycée
ont également à leur disposition un
arsenal réglementaire pour limiter la
propagation du virus
gants en plastique masques et gels
hydro-alcooliques
aujourd'hui nous devons juste faire en
sorte de ne pas être trop proches les
uns des autres et de garder nos
distances je crois que la phase iib
faire et donc je ne suis pas certaine
que ce soit un problème majeur pour nous
ici en islande le déni a été plutôt bien
gérée par le gouvernement
personnellement je ne connais personne
qui a été malade
je me sens donc totalement sécurité pour
revenir au lycée une gestion de la crise
sanitaire parfois cité en exemple par
les islandais eux mêmes et qui est
surtout due à une campagne de dépistage
massif de la population
associé à un ce traçage du virus dès le
31 janvier 2020 avant même que l' oms
déclare qu'il s'agissait d'une pandémie
13% de la population a été testé en
l'espace de six semaines à l'issue
desquelles l'épidémie a été déclarée
sous contrôle par l'exécutif islandais
la pandémie de kovy 19 n'est pas
terminée en islande mais nous maîtrisons
la situation
elle est sous contrôle il ya très peu de
nouveaux cas d'infection de 0 à 2 ces
derniers jours si l'impact sanitaire a
pu être limitée par le gouvernement les
secteurs de l'aviation et du tourisme ne
sont pas épargnés
récemment la compagnie aérienne
icelandair a annoncé devoir se séparer
de 2000 salariés
hélas le pays ne fait pas exception
et pour évoquer le cas histoire des nous
sommes avec jonas moody journaliste
bonsoir jonas maudit merci d'être avec
nous alors comment selon vous expliquer
ce faible bilan dont se targue l'islande
pour répéter s'il vous plaît comment
expliquer ce faible bilan
je ne suis pas sûr de pouvoir
l'expliquer mais je pense qu'il est
beaucoup de tests grâce au secteur privé
tout comme secteur public et il ya
quelqu'un à un traçage des contacts mise
en place très rapidement donc avec ses
connaissances dans plus mettre les
personnes en quarantaine rapidement il
est séparé de la population lorsqu'il
était contaminée donc cela a permis de
maintenir de gérer la pandémie
effectivement un dépistage massif à
l'instar d'ailleurs des pays qui ont de
faibles bilans justement on la corée du
sud taïwan ou bien même plus proche de
chez nous l'allemagne ça veut dire que
l'islande était préparé à ce type
d'épidémie
je ne sais pas si nous étions mieux
préparé mais c'est en tout cas la
réaction a été rapide et l'équipe était
menée par des scientifiques les milieux
politiques qui n'étaient pas ce premier
plan cela nous a sans doute aidé alors
ce qui est intéressant ni stand c'est
qu'effectivement il ya eu ce dépistage
massif mais l'histoire contrairement à
la plupart des autres pays n'a pas
imposé de confinement à sa population
juste l'observation des gestes barrières
quel a été le comportement justement de
la population à ce niveau là très
respectueuse a sans doute islandais ne
sont pas vraiment très partisan des
règles donc je ne sais pas si les
personnes
suivait de très près les consignes à
mais il ya d'autres mesures telles que
justement les tests à grande échelle et
le traçage des contacts j'ai en tant
qu'étranger vivant en islande
j'étais assez inquiet mais en tout cas
la situation marchait bien car le taux
de contamination a baissé les décès il y
en a très peu
mais c'est assez difficile pour les gens
et ils ont bien envie et d'ignorer ses
consignes à je vis à reykjavik
et je marche pas mal dans la rue et je
n'ai pas vu beaucoup de gens observer la
règle par exemple des de m très peu de
personnes essayent de garder leurs
distances
les gens se rendent au restaurant
parfois les restaurants 1 met en place
dès distanciation mais pas tout le temps
il ya beaucoup de laxisme et cela est
préoccupant mais avec plus nombreux si
bas je ne sais pas si c'est nécessaire
de celles effectivement vous vous nous
faites un petit peu rougis pas trop en
gros vous êtes en train de dire que pas
grand monde ne respecte quoi que ce soit
en islande en terme de deux voilà deux
gestes barrières n'y a pas de
confinement mais que à la faveur des
tests massive et d'un traçage les choses
fonctionnent plutôt bien
soit en tout cas on retiendra c'est ces
informations on y réfléchira
il ya également un retour dans les
lycées et les universités qui est de
mise en ce moment ça aussi vous faites
des choses à l inverse fin de la france
où les lycéens ne sont pas prêts de
retrouver les bancs de leurs
établissements
comment a été accueillie cette mesure en
islande effectivement les plus grands
qui retournent à l'école louis hornec la
réouverture des écoles n'est pas très
bien comprise
les universités ne rouvre pas vraiment
la plupart des personnes finissent leur
semestre à distance c'est vrai également
pour la plupart des lycées merci merci
je n'applaudis d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france pour nous exposer
la situation islandais vous restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur les crises du coroner
virus en france y at il eu un patient
zéro du virus dans notre pays et ensuite
nous parlerons de l'application stop au
bic qui permettrait de tracer et
d'identifier les personnes atteintes du
comique 19 nous parlera enfin des
couturières professionnels qui ont
interpellé le gouvernement pour être
rémunéré après la confection de milliers
de masques
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je reçois jeunes shilton le père de
julian assange fondateur de wikileaks
est actuellement derrière les barreaux à
londres selon les avocats du
gouvernement américain julian assange
aurait mis en danger la vie de ses
sources de sa chasse c'est tout
simplement faux effet wikileaks
coopérait avec 90 autres organes
d'information pour filtrer expurgée et
analyser les câbles à 65 ans julian et
son équipe ont essayé de prévenir le
département d'état mais on les a ignorés
qu'est-ce que ça en dit sur la liberté
d'expression d'après vous notamment dans
les pays occidentaux
il n'y a pas de liberté d'expression ça
il s'agit d' intimidation et
d'oppression des journalistes en
prennent soin afin que le public ne
dispose pas des informations nécessaires
pour juger les systèmes dans lesquels
ils vivent
personne aucun journaliste n'est prêt à
tenir tête aux états unis après ce que
julian a subi ce band
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour tenter de limiter l'impact de cette
crise économique liée aux colis de 19 un
plan de soutien à hauteur de 110
milliards d'euros a été déployée
restaurons des sociétés d'événementiel
des indépendants vont mettre la clé sous
la porte
quelles que soient les aides qui leur
seront accordés à gaza derrière si
l'économie ne repart pas si la confiance
ne repart pas elle m'a traitée de vous
savez aujourd'hui on perd près d'un
million d'euros par jour et on peut
considérer que non seulement avril mais
aussi le mois de mai sont désormais
certains est fermé donc c'est près de 50
millions d'euros qu'on a perdu ans et
deux mois on résout le truc en laissant
en laissant les choses se faire et en
bloquant complètement le l'économie
française
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups positif n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent là l on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoint pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité une
bonne rentrée scolaire plutôt qu'une
rentrée en nombre emmanuel macron a
tenté de rassurer et dissiper les
inquiétudes ce matin lors d'une visite
dans une école de la région parisienne
emmanuel macron qui a précisé que ces
décisions pour le confinement seront
prises jeudi prochain à l'issue d'un
conseil de défense
l'application mobile stop qu'aux vives
pourrait faire son apparition début juin
elle rentrera en phase de test dès le 11
mai avec une présentation et un vote au
parlement la semaine du 25 mai son
objectif tracé et identifier les
personnes atteintes du coc vite 19 et
éviter des futurs contamination sans
avoir recours aux plateformes d'apple et
de google
[Musique]
rassurer et convaincre le chef de l'état
s'est donc exprimé à l'issue d'une
visite dans une école de poissy dans les
yvelines restés ouverts pendant le
confinement pour accueillir des enfants
de soignants accompagné de jean michel
blanquer le ministre de l'éducation le
président échanger avec des enseignants
et des enfants en insistant sur
l'importance des gestes barrières il est
revenu sur le protocole sanitaire très
stricte qui doit encadrer la réouverture
des écoles et qui inquiète bon nombre de
maires de communes le chef de l'état a
tenté de rassurer le 11
dans la plupart des écoles ce sera une
journée de prérentrée comme on le
connaît on fait la rentrée scolaire
parce que les enseignants
il ya des exceptions en a qui
accueilleront les enfants dès le 11 mai
la plupart du temps ce sera une journée
de prérentrée pour de prérentrée pour
s'organiser entre soi et le 12 ou le 14
il a volé ces deux là sur le terrain les
choix peut-être succès certes un peu
plus tard on va accueillir
progressivement les enfants
progressivement la semaine prochaine on
va rouvrir avec des classes qui seront
beaucoup plus réduite vous voyez mon
mais moins de table on peut pas
organiser la cantine de la même manière
on peut pas organiser et donc on va
devoir collectivement au plus près du
terrain avec beaucoup de pragmatisme
organiser des choses donc mon objectif
c'est pas combien d'écoles
c'est que tous les enfants qui ont
besoin de revenir à l'école parce qu'ils
sont décrocheurs parce qu'ils sont dans
des familles qui n'arrivent pas bien les
aider parce que le travail à distance
l'enseignement à distance n'est pas
adapté parce que les parents doivent
être retravaillé pour toutes ces raisons
que les enfants puissent trouver une
école ouverte avec un temps aménagé est
du côté des chiffres le bilan l'épidémie
coronavirus dans l'hexagone est tombée
on compte 25 mille cinq cent trente et
un décès au total en france soit une
hausse de 330 morts ces dernières 24
heures le solde reste négatif en
réanimation avec 266 malades ducobu de
19 ans - du côté de la carte la région
au de france passant orange en raison de
la baisse de la tension hospitalière et
lui étaient déjà atteints du coc vite 19
un mois avant l'apparition des premiers
cas en france son nom
amirouche a marre il faudrait donc
office du nouveau patient de nouveaux
patients 0 est la fin du mois de
décembre cet homme de 53 ans s'était
rendue aux urgences de l'hôpital
jean-verdier à bondy en seine saint
denis pour ceux qui pensaient être une
grosse grippe mais après une double
vérification du service de réanimation
dans lequel il a été admis il était déjà
porteur du coronavirus il témoigne de
son expérience au micro d'rtl france
m'ont pris en charge et là ils ont
commencé à faire des examens la prise du
son et après je pense 3e après man
remonter un temps mort de réanimation il
faut que vous messieurs oxygène parce
que j'avais vraiment du mal à respirer
et leçons s'arrête pas de la veille
jusqu'au matin je continue à cracher du
sommet la de le re monte plus en plus là
de leur montre quoi franchement d'aix et
ses dix coups de couteau
c'est ce que le téléphone sonne séduits
bonjour mtv bonjour monsieur lamarre
jeudi c'est monsieur m'a dit vous étiez
admis à l'hôpital là chez nous au mois
de décembre et le 27 décembre et pour
une grippe saisonnière mais
appartenaient apparemment il va baisser
si vous avez eu de covile 19 monsieur
marc vidal et comment ça se fait au fil
des âges s'étaient mois de décembre a
dit si si vous avez vous été positif au
corps 19 et se sont retournés hier aux
examens et aux patients qui ont passé au
mois de décembre et début janvier des
patients qui sont malades
pour des problèmes de grip cessionnaire
anormal
sur les 24 patients il m'a dit vous êtes
le seul à être positif pour qu'on lui
dise non on est passé à côté de quelque
chose quoi mais c'est vraiment c'est
cette retraite de l'heureux est vraiment
vraiment rose expérience dieu merci j'ai
franchement j'ai échappé à quelque chose
d'assez morte est mois des milliers de
gens et pour en parler nous sommes avec
le docteur bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes bonsoir docteur le grand
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france c'est vrai que ce témoignage nous
apporte son lot de surprises
un mois avant les premiers patients
officielle en france on apprend que ce
monsieur était atteint du kobe de 19 est
ce que cela vous semble probable que ce
soit comme on dit le patient zéro en
france alors de nassian zemmour n'ont
sûrement pas moi je reste persuadé qu'on
a quand même une équipe qui est très
atypique est antérieure avant défendre
ce que je voudrais surtout dire c'est
que on est toujours à la recherche d'un
patient zéro comme si elle est une
personne responsable de l'entière
épidémie en france mais c'est marrant
parce que moi je sens quand même
énormément de personnes qui sont venues
de chine a augmenté petits délits et non
pas une personne qui aurait contaminé
toute la france c'est bien ensemble de
personnes revenant différentes porteuse
pour une certaine partie du virus à qui
a compté mené à différents endroits
donc cette recherche des patients 0 à
l'étatisme ans pour un storytelling est
satisfaisant pour le politique est pas
satisfaisante pour le médecin
alors justement vous allez nous éclairer
docteur parce que on parle souvent de ce
fameux patient zéro alors nos autres
novices voilà on comprends pas bien
cette notion
la présente comme tellement importantes
notamment peut-être dans la manière de
de trouver des remèdes contre le virus
info intente vous allez justement nous
éclairer sur ce point il
le version 0 en fait il est issu
probablement de chine jusqu'à preuve du
contraire
mais de là il avait multiplié il s'est
disséminée et donc le patient zéro en
france c'est comme rechercher un
coupable
et très sincèrement je me vois très mal
expliquer ça à mes patients donc c'est
pour moi c'est inacceptable de
rechercher comme ça aussi loin en
arrière et de faire porter sur un seul
homme le poids de l'ensemble des piles
et je suis pas du tout d'accord et je
pense que c'est l'inconséquence a testé
massivement des départs en face en face
d'eux parce que des crs nous ont mis des
protocoles qui nous empêchait de tester
et moi je me rappelle très bien avoir
fait une garde où je voyais un patient
qui était h 15 d'un retour de chine que
l'on n'a pas testé et il ya ce passe
temps à j 15 septembre il a contaminé
lyon c'est bien la responsabilité des
ars qui ont vomi un travail les
scolaires de premier de la classe mon à
la pique et des protocoles dont on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il ne marche pas et reste
comme un agence régionale de santé il
n'empêche docteur qu'est ce que ça
change cette découverte passion 0 ou pas
vous vous nous dit qu'il y avait
probablement d'autres passions dès
décembre en france qu'est ce que ça
change 7 entre guillemets découverte
aujourd'hui confortée en fait la
puissance du de la transmission par des
gens asymptomatiques qui n'ont pas pu
être suffisamment nombreux
non heureusement assez symptomatique
pour déclencher une alerte
ça prouve qu'en france on n'a ni
beaucoup trop temps a déclenché une
alerte
et que pendant le moment où ce monsieur
a été hospitalisé avec un étiquetage
grippe
malheureusement il est en réalité
étiqueté commis 19 et on nous envoyait
dans le même moment des mails nous
expliquant comment devaient repérer un
patient que vides alors que nous on
était en train de se dire mais détesté
ce monsieur a tout testé ce monsieur
et voilà donc j'essaie voilà c'est un
mail à nouveau pour lui car
effectivement l' oms a averti c'est le 8
décembre sur la circulation d'un virus
sur le territoire chinois
ça veut dire selon vous que les pays
occidentaux dans leur ensemble ont pris
trop à la légère cette potentielle
épidémie sur leur sol une contamination
interhumaine qui se passe en chine dans
une usine du monde avec nos acheteurs et
les hommes d'affaires sont là bas c'est
ridicule de penser qu'il n'y aurait pas
de contaminer ce pont sur notre sol
on n'a d'ailleurs pas testé et vérifié
les gens se moquent si vous êtes très
très classe sur la question donc le
monde est ainsi fait une circulation de
personnes et si vous avez une épidémie
dans le gérant dé retrouver millions il
ya peu de chances qu'elle se contaminent
à messimy en plein milieu leschi
évidemment que elle devient mondiale en
48 heures est ce que ça veut aussi dire
que le chiffre des contaminations par
conséquent été sous-estimée dans notre
pays clairement est clairement le sud
les contaminations des pentes nombre de
textes que vous faites si vous testez
personnes vous n'avez aucun chiffre et
comment ça se fait que la france soit
championne du monde du test positif
c'est parce qu'on ne fait pas enfin dans
une division il ya un dénominateur est
un homme honnête
donc si l'on s'amuse à faire de test on
a très peu de cas positifs mais ça fait
des mois et des mois que l'ensemble des
unités médicales de 10 si vous le voulez
bien docteur legrand vous restez avec
nous puisque on va parler de cette lutte
contre le virus avec l'application
mobile stop kobe plus que jamais
d'actualité selon le secrétaire d'état
au numérique cedrico elle sera prête le
2 juin après une phase de test dès le 11
mai le projet sera ensuite présenté et
voté au parlement la semaine du 25 mai
stop coville devrait permettre via des
smartphones de tracé et d'identifier les
personnes attein ducobu 19 et éviter de
futures contamination sans avoir recours
il faut le préciser aux plateformes
d'apple et de google docteur bertrand
donc vous restez avec nous pour en
parler stanislas françois avocat au
barreau de paris nous a rejoint pour les
parties peut-être plus juridique ça nice
françois merci de nous avoir rejoints en
direct sur rt france les plis stop au
vide qui va être donc prête à priori le
2 juin
une bonne nouvelle pour le juriste que
vous êtes vous êtes plutôt méfiants mais
sinon c'est bien sûr que méfiant mais je
vous demande à voir moi ce que la
nouvelle interrogé sur cette application
c'est de quoi avons nous besoin journée
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de tests
qu'ils soient généralisés donc une
campagne de dépistage massif et puis de
l'autre côté on a besoin de masques donc
il ne faudrait pas que le recours à cet
outil qui c'est l'application stocks au
vide
elle reçoit un espèce de contre-feux qui
s'est allumé pour pallier les
défaillances originel et dans le cadre
de la lutte contre cette épidémie la
défaillance originale sur les tests et
les masques donc ne voyons pas non plus
dans l'application snob qu'ovide un
outil miracle et qui permettrait de
lutter efficacement contre contre
l'épidémie
moi je rappelle ce que disait le premier
ministre lors de son allocution
nationale 28 avril dernier lorsqu'il a
présenté en ce qu'il représente et le
landais confirmant le premier ministre
nous à vie il a d'entrée de jeu en
écarter ce sujet sur l'application
stocks au vide en disant que compte tenu
des incertitudes sur cette application
est bien qu'il était bien en peine de
savoir comment elle fonctionne et
comment elles seraient susceptibles
d'être les enveloppes
après évidemment le juriste de
nombreuses questions se posent sur la
protection des données personnelles
il a la garantie des libertés publiques
tout à fait alors qu'en pense le docteur
le grand parce que on a vu un petit peu
plus tôt dans le journal il y avait
l'exemple islandais ou le tracking et
racing semblait plutôt avoir de bons
résultats on a vu aussi que c'était le
cas en allemagne en corée du sud en
taiwan est ce que c'est un outil qui
vous semblent indispensables docteur en
pharmacie pour cent de test donc on fait
feu contenir et aimante et plus traqué
voilà comme des 10% tests sur une
population
vous pouvez faire du tracking ça va pas
changer les bases de choses ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que nous avons un
texte qui a une sensibilité n'est pas
bonne ce qui veut dire que plus on
concentre les champions que l'on va
tester et puis nous allons produire des
faux négatifs que nous avons libéré dans
la nature c'est juste le théorème de
thalès c'est quelque chose qu'on apprend
première année de médecine
donc du coup concentrait la population
tester mais pas une bonne idée
la bonne idée c'est justement de tester
un grand nombre de personnes
c'est juste fini d'en signer des
pétitions mais docteur tout simplement
les tests et le tracking est ce que ce
nom pas ce ne sont pas deux outils
finalement qui ont besoin l'un de
l'autre on a vu que ça a été le cas très
tôt en allemagne on a testé très en
amont et ensuite on a isolé et on avait
tracé les gens finalement pour pas
qu'ils se rencontrent pour les lisent
les isoler est ce que l'un ne va pas
sans l'autre finalement pour une
efficacité maximale
il faut isoler systématiquement toute
personne qui est suspecte de colis de
sang la tester c'est à dire sur le
diagnostic du médecin est une personne
qui serait dans un groupe contact vous
peu de tester si les affaires
automatique par contre si les femmes
automatique elle n'a aucun sens d'être
testé si on se concentre uniquement sur
lesquels contacts à ce moment là on va
entraîner une augmentation de la
concentration des champions et on va
augmenter le nombre de faux négatifs que
l'on va relâcher dans la nature donc par
définition même chercher une
augmentation de la concentration du test
est une erreur il faut tester en
population générale selon la presse en
général de proposer à tous
stanislas françois vous évoquez vos
craintes concernant les libertés
individuelles
avec cette application en quoi ça
pourrait être un problème que l'état
garde finalement les des données qui
sont supposés de personnel c'est ce qui
vous inquiète le plus en tant que
juriste
oui bah c'est de toute façon c'est une
application qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la protection des données
personnelles
déjà de souffler dans les six mises au
jour également général la protection des
données vont être définies par le palois
l'union européenne donc c'est la
possibilité de devoir transmettre à
l'état notamment des données sensibles
pour une utilisation sont aujourd'hui on
ne mesure pas les effets se pose la
question de savoir qu'est ce que l'état
pouvait bien faire le choix que cette
période de déconfinement s'est passé
qu'est-ce que cet outil aurait vocation
à perdurer parce que il doit être
utilisé jusqu'à la fin de mes fin de
l'épidémie
donc c'est pas il connaît pas
aujourd'hui le terme de l'utilisation on
peut craindre aussi des dérivations les
épées vie parce qu'il m'a utilisé
constitue un moyen de surveillance donc
sur pose aussi le problème de cette
application ou draps l'efficacité à la
morale et l'efficacité scientifique pour
résoudre la crise du corps à des virus
efficacité scientifique parce qu'ici se
pose la question du consentement qui est
indispensable c'est un outil qui ne peut
être utilisé que sur la base du
volontariat rebond à partir du moment où
seuls des utilisateurs volontaires
l'utilisent
on peut ajouter 1 2
son efficacité parce que ça veut dire
qu'il peut parler fassions pas être
généralisée ce qui m'inquiète ce qui
peut m'arriver sans durée c'est à la
fois la réalité des consentements et
puis d'autre part sa sincérité
parce qu'ici non les dans un climat
autour du corona virus le président de
la république nous a parlé de guerre on
a l'impression qu'on jouera pression
l'epr et peut on concourt à une sorte
d'hystérie planétaire autour de cette
question qui crée un climat anxiogène
qui voudraient altéré finalement la
sincérité du consentement mois cet égard
j'ai une phrase ou secrétaires d'état au
numérique qui nous dit que chacun pourra
refuser ces outils pour des raisons
philosophiques mais cela reviendrait
dans ce cas accepter un risque
significatif de malades et de morts
supplémentaires donc ici on donne la
possibilité de refuser évidemment
l'application mais on fait peser sur les
l'utilisateur réfractaires bien une
sorte de culpabilisation qui pourrait
altérer la réalité et la sincérité de
son consentement à l'utilisation de la
cnil en tout cas doit se prononcer fin
mai docteur la dernière question pour
vous on a entendu les craintes du
juriste ça pose effectivement le la
question du secret médical vous vos
patients est ce que vous en avait déjà
parlé avec eux de cette application à ce
que vous les sentez plus tôt qu'on
s'entend avec un ce consentement éclairé
justement est bien faisait contre le
sida
en france les patients étaient
consentants pour rentrer dans un fichier
et les médecins ont refusé de faire ce
fichier
on a opposé notre secret médical pour
réaliser ça depuis les choses semblent
ne pas avoir beaucoup changé c'est à
dire que les patients seraient prêts à
rompre le secret médical pour ça mais
cette fois ci c'est un petit peu plus
grave que dans les années 80 en demande
carrément aux médecins de dénoncer non
seulement leurs patients mais de
dénoncer aussi les contacts qui ne sont
pas leurs patients dans la même
application
et le tout pour une efficacité qui comme
jouer mixeur et tout à fait douteuse et
en dehors du fait qu'elle est très
douteuse de par le texte en lui-même
elle est aussi douteuse dans son
application c'est à dire que 525 milles
qu'à contacter par semaine ça fait
vingt-cinq contact de ces personnes qui
sont des contacts de contact vous êtes à
7 millions de personnes
on est déjà en population réelle ça n'a
plus aucun sens vous avez m de 23000
personnes qu'ils sont ni médecin ni là
ni l'infirmier qui sont soumis à aucune
déontologie qui parfois sont hôtesses de
l'air pour aller rendre visite à des
malades pour leur faire un test invasif
on va enfoncer quand même un coton tige
dans la narine avec des risques qu'ils
sont quand même pas négligeable ni pour
la personne qui le fait unis pour les
personnes qui le subissent
et tout ça sans aucune référence à la
déontologie médicale
depuis quand quelques rides art de faire
un acte médical à ces nouveaux enfin je
ne sais pas c'est un tout nouveau en
france
merci en tout cas tous les deux docteurs
bertrand et stanislas françois avocat au
barreau de lyon merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct avec nous on en vient cet
appel des soignants pour un mouvement
populaire qui a résonné chez les
couturières après le mouvement soignants
bas les masques
les couturières professionnels
qui se sont mobilisés à titre bénévole
pour confectionner des masques ont
interpellé cette semaine le gouvernement
pour que les heures passaient derrière
leurs machines soient rémunérés pour en
parler
nous sommes en direct avec marisa
garnier couturière bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
pourquoi cet appel au gouvernement le
collectif bas les masques donc qui
interpelle les autorités
c'était au départ du bénévolat ça se mue
progressivement au travail gratuit pour
quelles raisons bonsoir
alors c'est vrai que au démarrage lors
du démarrage lors du début du
confinement
on a été très nombreuses couturière à à
se mobiliser pour fournir des masques
aux personnels soignants et aux
travailleurs de première ligne
c'est vrai que vu les manquements de
stocks on sait tout tout de suite en
parreno aiguilles et petit à petit
notamment à l'annonce du déconfinement
le 11 mai plus de plus en plus de
demandes soient arrivées plus seulement
des soignants mais vraiment en des
entreprises qu'ils allaient réouvrir
comme des particuliers qui voulaient se
protéger eux et leur famille
et là ont commencé à venir énormément de
demandes des demandes plus ou moins
compréhensible ou agressive envers les
couturières qui qu'ils n'acceptaient pas
forcément de faire du travail 100%
gratuit pour tout le monde car à
l'origine c'était quand même pour plus
pour subvenir aux demandes des
personnels soignants et ensuite ça s'est
vraiment énormément étendue et l'idée
c'est quand même de pouvoir pallier au
manque de masques dans l'urgence mais
pas que je ne mets pas que ça devienne
quelque chose de normal et d' accessible
à tous alors justement qu'attendez vous
clairement aujourd'hui du gouvernement
vous l'avez interpellé qu'est ce qui
vous a répondu
alors écoutez moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
connaissance d'une réponse à ce jour
mais mais a minima ce qui ce qui serait
intéressant d'avoir c'est déjà le
remboursement des matières premières
utilisées par toutes les couturières
bénévoles car lors du confinement on a
tout utiliser nos stocks personnel nos
machines à domicile machine familiale ou
machine ou machines industrielles pour
celle qui avait la chance d'en avoir
chez elle et tout ça ça représente quand
même une somme non négligeable pour pour
des indépendantes des tpe ou des
freelances du monde du costume et du
spectacle ou de du textile en général
donc déjà ça c'est un premier point à un
pouvoir se faire rembourser toutes ces
matières qui ont été tués a été donné
bénévolement et ensuite ce sera
intéressant en effet de pouvoir
comptabiliser les heures qui ont été
passées car on a tout passé des
centaines d'heures à créer des masques
et à l'uso créé gracieusement
donc voilà soit en salaire soit il ya
dix jours il ya plein d'autres
propositions qui sont faites sur par le
collectif lors de l'appel mais mais
voilà c'est vraiment lire les premières
revendications aujourd'hui clairement
quand on vous sollicitera puisque j'ai
compris que on le fait beaucoup et avec
parfois insistance quel sera votre
réponse
alors après dans dans le monde textile
il ya énormément de cas de figure
différent il ya des personnes qui
travaillent en société et qui pour
l'instant sont en chômage partiel à
domicile il ya des personnes qui ont des
tpe il ya des freelances il ya des
personnes qui travaillent pour dans le
monde du spectacle donc c'est à chaque
couturière et couturiers de mettre ses
propres règles pour ma part moi je suis
une créatrice indépendante et j'ai à
coeur de pouvoir offrir des masques de
manière si de manière solidaire à tout
le monde donc pour l'instant ma règle
c'est des masques les masques que
classique en coton qui suivent les
recommandations qui ont été faites
notamment par l'afnor je les propose à
prix libre pour chacun maintenant même
même ce prix libre créé quand même débat
et il ya une grande personne qui ne
comprennent pas que nous pouvons offrir
des masques gratuits pour tous car nous
avons la matière première à acheter des
frais sans même compter notre notre tour
r merci en tout cas marisa garnier je
rappelle que vous êtes couturière merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france et c'est la fin de cette émission
un peu écourtée vous le savez toujours
en raison de cette crise du coronavirus
l'actualité continue sur rt france
prochain point sur l'actualité demain
matin 8 heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée à tous
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une